the M1 MacBook Air revolutionized the
laptop industry but it came out in 2020
and it is now
2024 apple is still selling it even
though we now have the M3 MacBooks so is
it actually worth buying one well even
though last year I was telling people
yes in 2024 I would have to say no let
me explain the MacBook Air has been
iconic ever since Steve Jobs pulled the
original one out of an envelope and
shocked the whole world it was
incredibly thin and light and the first
Mac that really favored form over
function getting rid of a bunch of ports
to make it thinner and lighter with that
it was the first Mac to be shipped
without a CD drive ever since those came
out being the first to use all SSD
memory with very little capacity all
while being Ultra expensive at the time
fast forward to 2020 and the Mac finally
ditched its x86 processor for an
upgraded cell phone chip while Mass
possibly improving performance over the
previous version that came out the same
year and it did so without even having a
fan that was really an embarrassment to
Intel laptops especially because it now
costs $999 instead of ,200 for the much
weaker i7 and you can now buy this M1
MacBook Air for
$750 brand new on Amazon and for 750
bucks I would not buy it now let's start
with the design I have to comment on it
because I love it it has this iconic
wedge shape that has been around for a
long time that is now going away and I
love how it just tapers down and
especially love this gold color I even
miss and appreciate the MacBook Air logo
on the inside because the new ones don't
have that now as far as speakers this
thing has dual stereo speakers with
grills on the sides and they sounded
really really good when it came out
right now they still sound pretty good
but the M2 air has a quad speaker system
and the 15-in version of that has a six
speaker system that is louder and has
quite a bit better base so you will get
better audio if you spend a bit more
money the keyboard still feels really
nice and the trackpad is great as well
it's a little bit smaller than the newer
ones but it does the job now the thing
that always gets me when I open this
thing up are the bezels it was not bad
for the time but now they seem huge
compared to the new redesigned MacBook
Air and the 13.3 in display seems a lot
smaller than the 13.6 that's on that new
design because has thinner bezels it
also has that Notch which actually
doesn't take away from your screen
because you have added real estate at
the top there so it is a noticeable
difference now in terms of the actual
quality of this playay is itself it
supports DCI P3 colors just like the new
one so that is great it's nice and sharp
and the only kind of downside is that we
have uh 400 nits of brightness compared
to five or 600 on the newer ones now at
the top we have that webcam and it is
unfortunately
720p and nowadays it looks pretty bad
compared to the 1080p on the new ones
now of course not everybody is going to
care about that uh but I think it is
just nice to have something that looks
decent if you ever have to make a video
call or join a meeting now as far as
battery life it was so impressive when
it came out compared to its Intel
counterparts now Apple quotes the same
18 hours as it does for the new M2
version but in reality that is not
really what you get because they really
lower the brightness they've run a video
on the Mac itself to get those numbers
now in the real world world you will get
8 to 10 hours of mixed battery life
which is slightly worse than you can get
on the M2 version and then the new M3
chip is even more efficient than that
now with that you also don't get fast
charging so to charge up to 50% takes
more than an hour compared to just 30
minutes and that is really nice if your
laptop is dead or very low and you need
to run to be able to just plug it in and
get a lot of charge now the big thing
that I miss on this laptop now that we
have the new ones is the fact that it
doesn't have a MAG safe charging port um
now that is not only convenient because
it disconnects and connects easily so
you won't pull your Mac but with that it
frees up the two ports that you have
here on the sides to be able to do other
things and that is very handy now as far
as the ports Apple just lists
Thunderbolt for all of their base level
Max but this has Thunderbolt 3 compared
to four so for most people it might not
not matter but if you want to connect to
multiple accessories or a dock
Thunderbolt 4 is more powerful now one
of the biggest limitations with the M1
was that they only supported One
external display compared to the older
intels but with that said the M2 and the
M3 chips still only support one now on
the inside the Wi-Fi chip supports Wi-Fi
6 just like the M2 but the newer M3s
have Wi-Fi 6E which you might not even
have a router for that but in the real
world even using Wi-Fi 6 Wi-Fi 6E chip
will give you quite a bit faster speeds
and better range so that's is something
that I appreciate and now let's talk
about how this thing performs the M1
chip threw the smackdown not only on the
thin airs that it replaced but also with
its more expensive Windows Rivals that
had dual fan cooling which literally
became half of the M1 speeds if you
unplug them and the real world Therma
throttling wasn't actually that bad
compared to the desktop Mac Mini or the
M1 MacBook Pro that had a fan so we
ended up telling most people to skip
that one and just go for the air and
people listened and they loved it I
don't know if I have ever seen another
laptop with 4.8 Stars after nearly
20,000 reviews on Amazon with just this
one listing now the previous airs didn't
have that and the new ones are slightly
lower as well that just shows how iconic
and incredible this machine was and it
brought over over a bunch of Windows
fans to Apple even within the last week
we have new reviews from people that are
so impressed and it is true for most
people the M1 chip performs very well
even in 2024 beating out laptops that
people are replacing with this new
machine while it's even thinner and
lighter so why would I not buy one well
it has all to do with pricing and value
when it's replacement the M2 MacBook
airun launched it cost 1,200 bucks and
at that point I told people to just go
for the M1 which was discounted down to
900 bucks that is a 33% price difference
for the same amount of RAM and storage
and that's just something that you have
to take into account but now in 2024 you
can get an M2 air for 899 bucks only 149
more for a much updated machine and if
you're watching this video a bit after
it posted the M3 version will be on the
market now the new design isn't as
iconic but it is actually Slimmer and
lighter with that you get the max saave
charging port and the larger display a
better webcam better speakers better
battery life with fast charging and of
course better performance the new chips
do make it snappier in day-to-day tasks
and the graphics performance is also
really nicely improved and looking at
performance per dollar it really starts
to make sense to spend just just a bit
more and if you're not as budget
conscious the M3 version really improves
certain tasks because of new decoders
and Ray tracing technology so even
though you can buy one for 750 bucks it
is a computer that came out in 2020 with
a lot of 2020 Tech and features so
you're not getting as good of a value
compared to spending just a little bit
more and if you're like most people
you're not going to just have it for a
year you're going to have it for 2 three
four or even 5 years now if you are
really on a budget I would say go for
one but find it used for $500 or less
and then it really starts to make sense
again and when it's time for you to
upgrade you'll be able to get most if
not all of your money back so this is
still one of my favorite laptops ever
but in 2024 it is finally time for us to
stop recommending it let us know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below click that Circle above to
subscribe to see more videos and check
out that one right over there this has
been Max and I will see you in the next
[Music]
one